[Musique]
le président pierre-yves à la maison
blanche et qui vend les caméras et bien
se démasque ça nous emmerdent aux
trousses de le matin devoir prendre note
masques etc
mais je crois que c'est important de le
faire quand même pour protéger les gens
qui sont autour de nous j'ai tellement
appris sur le coronavirus est une chose
est sûre ne laissez pas le virus control
et n'en ayez pas peur vous allez loin en
créant mais avons le meilleur matériel
médical il avons les meilleurs
médicaments tous développé récemment et
vous allez le barreau je les ai entendus
dire qu'il ne fallait pas avoir peur du
corona virus allez dire ça aux deux cent
cinq mille familles américaines qui ont
perdu l'un des leurs tout ce qui est en
train de se passer aujourd'hui va être
impactée par la copie ce quinquennat
sera hélas celui de la coved
on voit maintenant au point où on en est
on a plus de morts on a géré avec +
d'affolement plus peut-être plus le trop
de communication trop d'énervement
deuxième semaine de juillet il y avait
moins de dix personnes qui étaient
admises en réanimation chaque jour
aujourd'hui c'est 150 personnes qui sont
admises en réanimation
chaque jour au 1er novembre ce sera 406
bien effrayant au 1er novembre
rer b rer d ligne 13 surchargé sur un
week-end à l'intérieur des rames des
images qui interroge alors que
l'épidémie repart moins de 1% des cas
les contaminations ont eu lieu dans les
transports en commun ou contrats ont
pour cause principale des transports
la plupart des contaminations observé
selon les données de cette plaie france
sont des contaminations qui ont eu lieu
dans les lieux festifs de socialisation
les bars et les restaurants notamment
salle des sports les universités dans
l'expression naviguer à vue il peut ya
voir l'expression qu' on ne saurait rien
de ce que nous faisons non tout est fait
à partir de tous les éléments que nous
pouvons connaître nous nous enrichissons
de ce que nous avons connu dans ces
derniers mois et puis surtout nous nous
enrichissons des études scientifiques
qui existent je suscite un nombre de
réactions que je croyais incroyable les
gens qui m'insultent qui se plaignent
auprès du conseil de l'ordre il ya une
cinglée là qui fouillent les 3500
publication que j'ai fait pour savoir si
je me suis pas tombé c'est pas que ça me
ça m'empêche de dormir là on va avoir
besoin de nous encore les gens de
province ne pourront pas monter pour
nous soulager mais pas en colère
on va tous y arriver et moi non moi je
suis un fils d'hospitaliers j'ai pas
envie de laisser tomber l'hôpital et
dans votre circonscription vous le savez
fort bien on aura l'occasion peut-être
tout à l'heure de se voir alors moi j'ai
pris
ma maman met ma main ma maman m'a pris à
part montrer du doigt c'est très très
très swing moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il va pas de main morte
vous êtes prêts dans son livre qui vient
de paraître le génie laisse bien l'élue
verte au conseil de paris déclare il ne
suffit pas de nous entraider il faut à
notre tour les éliminer les éliminer de
nos esprits de nos images d'une
représentation
je ne lis plus les livres des hommes je
ne regarde plus leurs films je n'écoute
plus leur musique
j'essaie du mois et quand par exemple
pauline art manche
une jeune auteur qui a publié un essai
intitulé moi de les hommes je les
déteste
a sion cette radicalité féministe est-ce
que ça sert la cause des femmes
je ne m'excuse pas si comme le vôtre
c'est le thé a dénoncé pendant longtemps
l'opium du peuple
bon soit désormais lié avec un islam au
gauchisme qui détruit la république
j'ai un désaccord avec la position d'
alice coffin c'est pas du tout ma ligne
moi au contraire je pense que l'enjeu du
féminisme c'est un humaniste mais c'est
de partager un même espace de vie et que
femmes et hommes on puisse s'épanouir
indifféremment de notre sexe et qu'on
soit pas assignée à une identité de
genre alors alice coffin n'en est pas à
son coup d'essai c'est une ancienne
journaliste à la 42 ans elle est une
militante de la cause lgbt
elle se bat contre la domination
masculine elle avait déclaré en 2018
toujours à propos des sommes que ne pas
avoir un mari sam exposé à ne pas être
violées ne pas être tués ne pas être
tabassés et ça évite que mes enfants ne
soient aussi